depuis le début de la pandémie de kobe
19 de plus en plus de personnalités
prennent la parole sur les différents
choix pris par le gouvernement entre
enfin pourquoi on peut s'en passer dans
le métro on peut parler au cinéma que ce
soit pour soutenir les mesures mises en
place ou au contraire pour dénoncer les
erreurs qui ont été faites depuis le
début ces gens-là santos ordre à et ils
sont aux ordres du pognon récemment
c'est laurent ruquier qui a tenu à
pousser un coup de gueule dans son
émission on est en direct samedi soir
s'en prenant directement aux médecins
qui interviennent régulièrement sur les
plateaux télé pour donner leur avis ce
que moi j'ai vraiment envie de
m'emmerder c'est tous les médecins qui
au lieu d'être dans les hôpitaux sont
sur les plateaux depuis deux ans à nous
raconter connerie sur connerie qui
profond qui ont fait vivement réagir sur
les réseaux sociaux bonjour laurent
ruquier votre comportement depuis le
début de la crise a montré un errement
entre théorie bringuebalante anti
vaccins ou complotistes matinée de
nombrilisme peureux de penser par un
seul instant que cela passera crème
bisous pourtant laurent ruquier est loin
d'être le seul à s'exprimer sur cette
épidémie alors déclarations de laurent
ruquier sur les médecins at il eu raison
alors merci aux livres livres de nous
rejoindre mon frère au haut niveau et
merci d'être là logiciel je fais un gros
bisou à ta maman regarde séville motion
c'est important tiens on est une info
médical qui est vive et novelli qui
m'écrit en direct qui est chez elle à
c'est un peu souffrante et c'est pas une
bague m10 est jolie alors alors un
cousin amaya manière c'est une amie elle
dit d'ailleurs un cousin bahia donc
c'est un cousin de match
[Rires]
a eu une troisième couilles à la cause
du vaccin et c'est pas une blague non
est ce que ça peut arriver ou bien il
aurait connu sa troisième coupe c'est
très tôt dans le package
non je vous jure que c'est vrai c'est
moins raisonnable c'est pas vrai bel et
bien possible non d'accord pas
supportable
[Rires]
non mais c'est toujours le roi c'est pas
une balle c'est palmade donc non mais
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
réagi laurent juste avant de revenir sur
laon quand tu disais sur les effets
secondaires que les mecs aurait eu la
maladie quoi qu'il arrive j'ai vu cette
personne a peut-être un cancer du
testicule faut peut-être ne va pas votre
pape est un site a pour elle une
troisième bosse dans l'été à côté des
testicules c'est jusqu'à prendre en
compte et regardez je crois que c'est
peut-être
c'est pas cher on sait pas mais en tout
cas on embrasse si on espère qu'il
valait mieux au niveau l'hiver si nous
avoir rejoints sur laurent qui qu'est ce
que vous en pensez sur laurent ok
d'ailleurs c'est quoi comme question
actives laurent ok at il eu raison voilà
la chanter oui ou non dites-nous vos
livres quand tu vois ça moi je pense
qu'il a raison de s'énerver laurent il
est temps d'aller dire un petit peu à
tous ces médecins qui raconte tout et
leur contraire en fait depuis des mois
bali manque de personnel dans les
hôpitaux je pense qu'il serait temps en
bas de rejoindre les hôpitaux parce
qu'on attend d'avoir des médecins ont
été les bains ou mois ci invite tout le
temps sinon on a besoin de la parole
aussi cyril mais on entend tous les
jours on a besoin des grands noms comme
laurent comme
comme martin blachier comme voilà on a
besoin d'eux aussi ouais on a besoin
d'eux mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui on
n'a plus besoin d'eux dans les hôpitaux
puisque apparemment ça en pénurie de
médecins c'est normal on les amis on les
a mis à pied en fait aujourd'hui les
gens dans le médical
donc forcément on est en pénurie de
médecins je pense qu'on a compris ils
ont rabâché rabâcher rabâcher rabâcher
bon bah je pense que maintenant c'est
bon donc il en a marre laurent et puis
c'est bien de voir moi je pense que
c'est bien de voir des gens comme
laurent aller en ville des cojones un
mois mais la récente raconter ses
paroles et je pense qu'il est temps de
les porter parce qu'en fait tout le
monde en a marre dans speed tout ce
qu'on peut entendre on en a tous sera
lui c'est un peu partout dans tous les
pays un peu pas il est passé je suis
d'accord avec
commence à taper fortement sur le
système honnêtement je sens que ça tape
sur le système de tout le monde alors
est-ce qu'il a eu raison vous dit non
non pourquoi parce que c'est trop facile
de taper sur les médecins et je prends
année mais pas sur les médecins sur les
médecins ces voix là on en a besoin au
plateau aussi oui mais il dit on sait
plus quoi faire quand il dit on sait
plus quoi faire oui mais globalement je
trouve qui tape trop sur tout le monde
et moi pour les médecins rappelez-vous
cyril lundi dernier le professeur
casalino qui était là il nous a éclairés
ne serait formidable donc je et laurent
il nous éclaire aussi une laurent est
formidable enfin
un couac
gère de globaliser comme il l'a fait je
trouve qu'il a raison de s'exprimer mais
sur le fond je trouve que canarder à
tout va comme ça ça discret dirait que
vous ne le faites pas
bon il a eu raison d'abord il a eu des
couilles parce que c'est le service
public qu'il paye doit bien sûr tout
perdre du jour au lendemain à vue pour
moins que ça compte dégager c'est
incroyable je dis que c'est bien qu'il
ait qu il a des couilles de faire ça il
le pense vraiment après je savais que la
sincérité du gars et ça pour moi c'est
le plus important moi je partage son
avis parce que parfois tu regardes sur
twitter les médecins qui te met à 10
heures ils étaient sûrs tels chaîne à 11
heures ils étaient là à 15 heures ils
étaient là bas 17h était là-bas à 20h
était là il a été quand à l'hôpital en
fait quand est ce qu'il est à l'hôpital
moi par exemple il ya des émissions je
peux pas faire le vendredi s'accorde pas
avec mes horaires parce que je suis en
train de travailler donc si tu es
médecin un temps en temps va un peu à
l'hôpital ça fait comme michel cymes qui
donne des conseils allez un peu valait
un peu voir les gens allaient un peu
l'hôpital moi je trouve qu'il a raison
c'est chiant et je vais même en rajouter
je vais en mettre encore une douille à
tous ces gens là tous ces gens qui nous
donnaient des leçons de liberté quand
quant au début du covin tous les
artistes et les comics je vais mettre
des potes à nouan jean marie bigard qui
tapait des coups de gueule n'y a plus de
coup de gueule nicolas bedos y a plus de
coup de gueule camille lellouche a plus
de coup de gueule berléand il n'y a plus
de coup de gueule les artistes
maintenant il ya la liberté ça les
dérange pas maintenant qu'on leur a fait
un petit pas ce sanitaires pour aller
les voir sur scène près que ça les
dérange pas avery pousser des coups de
gueule pour les français lundi ils ont
disparu les français y'a pus 1100 mhz
intime
[Applaudissements]
c'est d'époque l'on a eus ar oui non et
non pas ils ont peur aussi pour leurs
silhouettes pour le fric et pour la lors
leur métier en place et ça se complique
encore du sommet encore plus exactement
lumière exactement ce parce que laurent
ruquier je peux vous dire sur france 2
faire ça je vous lis 1 c'est vraiment
qu'on soit d'accord ou pas c'est juste
incroyable
j'aurais pu choquer surtout c'est la
réponse de léa salamé qui dit ah mais
vous avez sous savez vous n'avez pas le
droit d'être anti vague sur à l'antenne
en ricanant fin c'est quand même ça
habille les bons outils voit que sa
mission il pas des mecs n'ont que 4 des
choses les mecs comme ça sonne accueille
plus de présentateurs télé d'ailleurs
qui disait vous feriez cathy temps il
n'y avait pas démentir cyril dans la
télé actuelle qu'on a aujourd'hui a pas
beaucoup d'émissions on peut venir
s'exprimer et on peut dire des choses à
part la tienne je sais qu'on a voulu
faire ce vol
et ont déconné c'est pas parce que je
suis invité il ya beaucoup d'émissions
aujourd'hui on voit tout le temps les
mêmes je pense que ça serait bien
d'entendre un petit peu autre chose et
puis bang on dit vulgairement il a porté
ses fruits c'est bien qu'ils aient qui
continue de les porter en tout cas
mathieu non moi ce qui me choque a
baissé quand tu vas voir un généraliste
qui imprime de gorge et dit je suis
désolée je suis pas formés pour ça j'y
connais rien allez voir un orl et ben
sur les plateaux de télé comme il faut
beaucoup de médecins toutes les chaînes
bfm pardon veulent leur médecin et qu'un
a pas assez eh ben on à la professeur en
chirurgie esthétique qui votent expliqué
le co vide un nutritionniste un
podologue pardon nommé chacun ça mais ça
c'est vrai il y en a qui ne vont jamais
avec des locaux vides par par le pied à
l'arrêt c'est vrai mais tous les médias
mais je suis devenu l'homme fort
heureusement qu'il ya des médecins c'est
la toip les mamies daniel way moi je
veux dire au roi alors je suis d'accord
avec avec vous sur laurent ruquier c'est
un éditorialiste il c'est un animateur
amis non mais là dans la cendre au delà
donc c'est fort ce qu'il a fait en
revanche je suis désolé heureusement
qu'on a les médecins moi j'ai peur tout
le temps quand je regarde la télé
alors vous n'en savez rien du tout vous
avez
encore de l'aspirine et de tous les
médicaments que vous prenez tous les
jours des saignements des bdd et touche
mandé ma mère n'a jamais quasiment pris
blanc justement médecine yoplait kelly
vdev dit qu'il dit le cousin à fatoumata
une copine à
regarder alors il y en a une qui a pas
du tout aimé
ce qu'a dit laurent ruquier c'est dans
le service public sur france inter
sophia aram qui a défoncé laurent
ruquier sur france inter laurent sachez
quand on se fait défoncer par sur le
tram c'est plutôt une bonne
autonomie alors sophia aram nous
détestent c'est à nous aussi et je vous
dis pourquoi me déteste moi je vais le
dire à un moment ça y est parce qu'elle
arrête pas nouvelle elle voulait à
l'époque j'étais sur la chaîne comédie
et elle voulait intégrer comédie elle
avait fait des essais pendant une
semaine pour intégrer la bande de
comédie vous dit voilà je me dis voilà
je le dis et comme c'était
catastrophique malheureusement dominique
farrugia et l'ensemble de la chaîne moi
même on l'a pas rappelé et depuis elle a
une dent contre nous donc voilà donc
elle nous en met toujours une petite une
chronique mais laurent sache le tu sais
je vais te dire quand tu te fait
dézinguer par des gens sans talons c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle regarde
alors comment te dire bon je comprends
que tu en as marre parce que tout est
trop compliqué c'est pas contre toi il
faut grandir maintenant la vie n'est pas
simple d'ailleurs au fond de toi tu sait
intuitivement que la vie n'est pas
toujours comme on voudrait quand par
exemple tu aimerais qu'on arrête de dire
connerie sur connerie à la télé et que
tu n'arrives pas toi-même attar et et de
débiter connerie sur connerie avec
l'obstination d'un enfant de 4 ans
refusant d'admettre que le monde n'a
définitivement pas l'intention de
répondre à tes petits caprices merci
sofia je précise que laurent reggae
n'est pas anti vaccins qu'il est vacciné
que la mère de ce qu'ils pensaient qu'il
aime le dire
non mais c'est vrai qu'il lui a dit
alors servi comme il l'appelle dans les
couloirs de france inter nantes a fait
sa chronique non sophia aram
effectif ce que tu as dit il n'est pas
anti vaccins laurent ruquier on évalue t
mac siné n'a pas dit qu'on est bien sûr
qu'on le veut le vaccin ya pas de soucis
mais il faut arrêter de dire aux gens on
va vous piquez de force on va piquer
brewster vous allez dis pour vous pour
votre âge c'est efficace pour vous deux
professeurs bien sûr que c'est efficace
pour vous mais vous avez aussi dit et
devant les caméras les gens ont entendu
vous avez aussi dit le vaccin il est
moyen vous même vous l'avez dit c'est
vos mots mais devra poser l'acte et
source vous a posé la question est-ce
que le vaccin et bien vous avez dit il
est monté hier passant alors il vaut
mieux si un professeur dit ça comprenez
que des français a bien sûr au moins la
peur ça se contrôle pas manquer -
comprenez ça c'est non mais surtout sûr
qu'il faut dire la vérité ça fait deux
ans les gens en ont ras-le-bol oui les
gens sont à cran les gens sont à bout
donc effectivement les gens en ont marre
c'est vrai que moi j'ai déjà dit que ma
profession 1 ou docteur on devait faire
une petite crise d'humilité parce qu'on
s'est contredit dans le temps regardez
pour prendre juste un exemple mais je
dis aime at-il dit raul qui à elles deux
ans avaient dit qu'ils n'allaient pas
s'inquiéter pour deux chinois trois
chinois qui meurt et que c'était moins
grave que les accidents de protein est
et que grâce à la chloroquine sa lettre
l'infection respiratoire la plus facile
à traiter l'histoire n'en est pas tous
les jours sur des plateaux
les pratiques
cyril boulleaux mais que toi il sait
jamais plateau normalement c'est sûr
copains et de jean
médecin se sont convertis en face time
et c'est chez nous et chez laurent ok
c'était chez jean marc morandini où
laurence ferrari fait qu 3d mieux
globalement et ben je crois que le corps
médical doit réfléchir à sa
communication
qu'il faut tourner sa langue sept fois
autour de la bouche avant de l'ouvrir et
par les médecins n'ont pas été
suffisamment
n'ont pas fait suffisamment attention de
leur communication deux ans mais en deux
ans on a le temps de beaucoup de
contredire elle
finance la présence des médecins formés
sur laurent ok oui la présence des
médecins sur les plateaux en fait depuis
le début de l'épidémie et surtout au
début on était pendu à leurs lèvres
parce que c'étaient les seuls qui
avaient la légitimité de nous dire
qu'est ce qui se passe au fur et à
mesure il ya tellement de chamboulement
alors oui on a besoin des médecins sur
les plateaux mais on a besoin des
médecins qui disent vrai alors laurent
alex ans quand vous dites que tous ces
effets secondaires ce sont des ce sont
des coïncidences
là vous ne dites pas vrai c'était ça le
problème
sur les plateaux et disent vrai il n'ya
pas de souci mais vous ne pouvez pas
nier le fait les gens ont des effets
secondaires extrêmement plat ne peut pas
qu'être déco ainsi le minus a jugé ces
gens là les moeurs c'est pas trop ça
l'objectif d'atteinte à la liberté qu'on
subit actuellement je peux vous dire que
dans les manifs c'est pas des
hurluberlus c'est pas des fachos c'est
pas des gens incultes qui n'ont pas
d'intelligence comme vous l'avait dit
lors d'une conférence à polytechnique
comme les gilet jaune que ce sont des
gens qui sont bas d'un niveau
intellectuel sent-il au nassau docteur
alexandre formation des gens que j
avais tes géraldine dans les
manifestations mois que j'étais alors je
vous explique j'étais dans la vallée du
5e siècle alors savoir la vérité je ne
vois pas la vague manifestation comme ça
moi je suis à leur manifestation on nous
a bloqué l'accès là que les policiers
nous ont bloqué l'accès moi j'ai demandé
parce qu'il fallait faire 5 km de plus
pour récupérer son métro j'ai demandé à
passer parce que j'ai vu des gens qui
passaient jeudi boba bon pour eux je
pourrais pas passer je passe sauf qu'en
fait ils te demandais tué manifestants
ou tuer simples passants alors si tu as
ps vous répondez simples passants tue
pas c'est si tu étais manifestants tu
n'avais pas envie de passer il a fallu
que je fasse un sketch avec ma carte de
presse pour faire passer les 30
personnes pour qu'on aime on aille on
puisse aller récupérer notre métro voilà
pourquoi les gens s'énervent voilà
pourquoi les gens s'énervent guillaume
genton sur les manifestations machnouk
c'est encore un bel exemple de
manipulation médiatique ça comprend
quelques cas isolés de violence on les
met en avant dans les médias pour dire
les antilles mecs sont des gens fous et
des gens violents mais où est ce qu'il
est la violence en réalité elle est du
côté des pros backs sur le fond quand
ils disent qu'ils veulent emmerder les
français non vaccinés sur la fin quand
il les met à l'écart qui les traitent
comme des pestiférés qui les empêchent
de vivre et il faut rappeler quand même
que les anti pacs sont dans la tolérance
ils veulent simplement avoir leur propre
liberté là où les pro bac veulent
imposer leurs idées à tout le monde donc
la violence et leur côté de ces votes
mon coeur c'est vous l'assuré c'est moi
j'ai envie de l'embrasser réussi
faites gaffe
ils partent à vide gérard oui j'ai cette
question alors effectivement donc tout
ce qu'on nous dit depuis depuis deux ans
maintenant c'est la fecq news c'est du
complot le vaccin attendant le vaccin ne
sert à rien ou a très peu été
satisfaites du vin c'est un toit ben je
répète ce que disent les mecs mais
pourquoi se regardant mais est ce que tu
es satisfait on va savourer et voudrait
nommer ce côté satisfaite du vaccin mais
je trouve quand ça répète alors rien non
mais si le temps même quand on est
satisfait j'ai eu longtemps qu est ce
qui est ma mère par rapport à mal et
pourquoi que ce temps c'est gênant c'est
que en fait ma mère est médecin et donc
je lui fais confiance ce que je fais
confiance à tous les gens même opérer
métier en vo thi alors je sais pas ce
qui vous dit mais moi ma mère je me fais
compagnie mais je fais confiance
qui vous dit dit comme vous dans le menu
des vidéos il est pour le voilà
maintenant et pour la commune mais oui
mais on peut être déçu mais il ya des
pros max qui sont déçus d'une
arrière-garde le professeur thomas non
mais quel intérêt de dire super on est
déçu de moi j'estime que dans le monde
entier il faut avancer ah oui mais on
avance kouao pas être comme des moutons
à mon nom mais faut pas le chauffer au
bois dans mes questions mais dany même
si on est même si on éprouve axe on peut
se poser un moment la question le vaccin
on voit bien qu'on n'est pas dictée par
cas des professeurs comme le professeur
copé en a un qui disent que le vaccin
n'est pas terrible mais j'ai quand même
fait le contraire puisque moi je les ai
eus alors que j'ai trois doses
magnifique symptomatique mais que si
vous en savez que vous auriez été malade
et je n'entretiens sa part nous vous le
savez pas mais je ne sais pas mais je
pense que je fais confiance mes enfants
n'ont pas attrapé j'estime que j'étais
moins contagieuses peut-être que je me
très bien être que je me suis bien au
départ et j'estime que c'est en mai mais
c'est vrai que le vaccin n'est pas fini
- c'est donc surtout et sûrement il est
peut-être pas fou mais je me dis quand
même qu'il ya un an on n'était pas
vaccinée les restes ont été fermées les
bars étaient fermés les cinémas mais
c'est pareil ils étaient fermés
tu peux aller voir un spectacle
aujourd'hui a été commis tomber des
atouts bal avec le masque si les
relâchera nature valley avec ton masque
et enlever les masses normal de donner à
qr codes que tout que le restaurateur il
soit obligé de contrôler ton identité
pour entrer dans un genre à rester rien
tu trouves ça normal tous les aspects
rappelons que tu trouves ça a été une
aubaine que les enfants disent on vous
que les enfants de plus de 12 ans sont
obligés d'avoir à passer le bac signale
pourra faire des activités je trouve que
c'est normal les enfants je troque le
masque de 8h à 10h le masque il est de
retour où ça normal au mali la tourbe en
attends tu bats il voulait pas rester
sous les deux jours en manifestation il
y avait des gens vaccinés et des gens
pas vers 2010 et pour la liberté c'était
terrible